Keegan Michael Key I gotta tell you man
my 10 year old self would lose his mind
knowing that this movie even exists like
you know like what about your does your
10 year old self even understand the
fact that you could be in it no my 10
year old self does not understand that
my 10 year old self cannot even
comprehend that I'm in this movie no it
has been such a privilege and such a
wonderful experience to make and I know
I mean it's I I can't get my head Carlos
wrapped around how huge this is you know
what I mean for 10 year old Minds for 30
year old Minds for 50 year olds yes you
know yeah what's super cool too is you
get to play this character who like
I mean I don't think anybody has any
idea about who toad is or was unless
they're really like really deep into
like playing certain games right
how did you get in there find this voice
and also maintain that like high-pitched
like you you're doing long sessions yeah
oh do you go in there and maintain that
without like uh burning yourself out
while you're doing it well first of all
gallons and gallons of Earl Gray tea
with honey and lemon there's that you
know and then the other thing the the
other thing was
um just literally I just had to use my
imagination I'd imagine I was on helium
that I was and for some reason just
thinking about that allowed me to stay
up there and also doesn't hurt to wear
tight pants so you know that right well
I mean in a way it hurts in a way it
could hurt yes absolutely you're right
you're right yeah but anything for my
art Carlos anything for my art you know
so
um again so you get to play this guy who
like I I guess even as a gamer myself
you're like who is Toad what is Toad's
motivation so when you're going in there
how much room do you have to actually
play and get to make him a character
that you uh yourself can relate to it
was it was actually it was actually
quite uh quite easy because you got to I
got to have those conversations with the
director Michael and we we talked about
and also the writing in the in the um in
the script whether it ended up on The
Cutting Room floor or not were lots of
things that gave me a sense of who toad
was and how he sees the really the
biggest thing foretold was how he sees
the Mushroom Kingdom it's such a sacred
place to him and when he first
encounters Mario the thing that he wants
to do more than anything is show Mario
where he's from it's like civic pride he
has this like Ultra civic pride that
anybody from any anywhere would have you
know I'm from Detroit I would love to
show anybody Detroit if you're from
Toronto Toronto would be the same thing
and and so it's it's um that was one
thing that motivated him is that so not
only showing off the Mushroom Kingdom
but protecting the Mushroom Kingdom
ultimately
okay so if you had to play only one
Mario game for the rest of your life not
none of them exist other than this one
game what are you picking what are you
playing well I have two ways of going
there I would either go Donkey Kong
which is my original game that I used to
you know the ogdk okay that I that I
that I played when I was a kid this
which was which is what introduced me to
this world but other than that I would
love to be an expert I would love to get
better and better and better at Mario
Kart I really would like yeah like maybe
in the most recent maybe Mario Kart 8 or
something like that where I could really
and just like be just be throwing
Turtles all over the place and just
knocking people off I would love to be
able to do that you say I would love to
I say you will ah I think you can thank
you Carlos yeah I think I might have the
means I may have the means absolutely
dude thank you so much for this time uh
and yeah I'm very much looking forward
to watching this movie again so
fantastic congratulations all right
we'll see you bye-bye